hello can you hear me yeah okay uh I'm
going to start my name is Daniel
Rodriguez and I'm going to be talking
about quering 1.8 billion ready comments
with python uh you can find the link to
the presentation on that GitHub repo so
about me D Rodriguez I'm a data
scientist and software developer at
continu analytics analytics we do
anakonda and I work in anakonda cluster
um originally from bota Columbia and I'm
in Austin Texas you can find on Twitter
on GitHub on my blog I do a lot of data
science
stuff uh so what is this talk about
quing 1.8 billion writing comments with
python um and how can you do it with
free tools that you uh threee open
source tools and one proprietor tool but
we're going to talk about how you can do
it for free
anyways uh we're going to talk about
three things one is the data science
friendly clusters uh please marketing
don't use this this is just a real thing
ETL uh because if you're data scientist
you have to DOL like it or not nobody
likes it but you have to and we're going
to talk about some data formats uh
especially
parket uh and finally how to query the
data using new python libraries to
Target not local files but remote
distributed engines and in this case
it's going to be Impala I'm going talk
about Impala uh this talk assumes a
basic uh knowledge of Big Data tools
like htfs my produce spark something
similar and everything is in this blog
that we meet and a coworker wrote for in
the blaze blog um you can find it there
okay the first thing is what the what is
the data and the data comes from Reddit
and Reddit is like uh the front page of
the internet that's where all the memes
go and and be created people talk about
a lot of stuff from uh really dark stuff
to really interesting stuff gaming data
science Neuroscience everything you can
find everything on Reddit
uh and the data was released uh a couple
of months ago
but a r user who actually crawled
everything and put it into a dump Json
dumps uh originally it was 1.6 billion
comments uh it was compressed on bc2 but
uh Thea were Json and what I did was uh
upload everything to A3 uh the data is
uh on A3 is public is free continum is
hosting it thank you continum for
hosting the data uh we I try to upload
every new monly dump to the a street
bucket so you can CL keep uh playing
with the
data so
clusters um the Big Data Technologies
like the Hado who uh are here to stay
people are moving to them people are
stop stopping to use uh traditional data
warehouses and they're moving to
hdfs and there's really good management
tools uh for it and DeVos people uh and
those tools come from CLA or Horton
Works uh like CLA manager CLA director
or Horton works
sari and they have like really nice
features like automated deployment and
configuration uh monitoring and
Reporting they are like effortless I
don't know if that's effortless for real
but they try to make it easy uh to
travel shoot the stuff uh they have zero
D maintenance rolling upgrades and roll
backs so you like your cluster never
goes down when you are trying to update
a spark to any version and they have a
lot of security um they use C Barrow or
lb or whatever security you want to
use uh and then you have like the data
scientists that are not it people uh
they don't really care if maybe the
cluster goes down for a couple of hours
when you're updating your spark maybe
they don't care that much about security
um they just want to run their jobs so I
have like this concept of data science
friendly clusters uh but basically is uh
some of the features before plus some uh
features like data analysis packages and
environment management um multiple data
scientists have mul like multiple tools
some people like car some people like
like python uh and you want all your
data scientist to be in the same cluster
if if it's better for you and you want
to have uh environment management for
them uh there scien want interactive
access to the cluster uh everybody likes
the juper notebook um or jupyter
notebook uh maybe the cluster are
actually short living uh a data
scientist maybe doesn't need to run like
the topic for this it was like uh how to
deploy machine learning uh in production
and we were talking about like how you
can have
24/7 uh model running but for dat
analysis maybe you just have to create a
cluster do your analysis in a spark uh
get a solution and report to your
manager and usually that's fine in a lot
of
cases uh maybe you don't want an UI and
like I have a question mark at the at
the end of this because like this is uh
dependent on the case uh but like
personally I don't like UI I like the CI
I like to use the terminal uh I like
simple stuff um it lets meate faster so
uh maybe you don't need an UI um you
want freedom uh like all these cloud
data uh and Hardon Works tools are like
very uh VAR people like I said and they
are like okay I want to lock all my all
the data scientists I don't want them to
touch any file I don't want to touch any
package uh and data scientists like the
freedom like Anaconda is one of the
things that you can download and do
whatever you want you can create
environment you can create all the stuff
and data scientists are free to do
whatever they
want uh but um the thing is that you
still need to know what you're doing uh
you still need to know if you're going
to run on Amazon you need to know AWS
you need to know how to create a keeper
you need to know what a security group
is and you need to know what is SES like
uh my job is like 99% explaining how to
S people to instances uh and you need to
know that there is no there is no hide
you cannot hide it there's no magic like
uh people need to know what they're
doing so I'm going to talk about uh a
proprietary product from con analytics
that's called an AA cluster that
basically lets you do what uh what I
just
described so it's a resource management
tool that allows user to easily create
provision and manage bed met or
cloudbased clusters um it enables
management of qu environments on
clusters it provides integration
configuration and setup management for
Hadoop uh it supports Amazon or physical
machines uh or VMS if you even want uh
we have a lot of documentation there we
have a lot of examples go there and
check it out how do you install it you
can uh install using cond first you have
to create an anac workor account install
then contact client you log in using
your account and then you can download
it for
free it's not open source it's free for
four notes right now in the cloud or
bare metal but soon it's going to be uh
16 notes in the cloud and for inhouse uh
so we're trying to like be more open
about
it the way it works is really simple you
have to create two files and use the CLI
uh the first file is the provider file
and you define okay I want to use my CL
provider is C2 uh the key name name is
the key name that you have to go and
create into the Amazon console the
location is the a availability Zone that
you want in Amazon the private key and
the secret ID and the secret key are
your Amazon
credentials and that's the reason we
have to file so you don't have to share
your credentials with other people but
you can share your profile and the
profile is uh it defines a name it
defines a provider uh you define the
user that you have uh you have the for
Define unit Ami in this case you Bo to
124 uh so the user is the user you want
to save the number of notes then uh the
type of the instance in this case is a
M32 x large the root size of the volume
and the plugin that you want uh and this
is the profile that I used to create the
cluster that I that I used to run the
code that I'm going to show later uh so
install hdfs Impala hi and the python
notebook or the jupyter notebook now and
then you can just do like a cluster
create Impala cluster-b the profile uh
it's going to launch a cluster and it's
going to sell all the plugins for you um
it's really fast for this cluster you to
took maybe 15 minutes that is much
faster than a cler manager for example
that it takes a really long time and I'm
going to talk about why it's that fast
uh after
this uh in the E cluster command you
have uh a lot of options you have to
create to destroy the cluster you can sa
it's a it's a handy uh command only you
can execute remote commands so a cluster
CMD date is going to return the date
command in uh in all the nodes you can
for example install uh packages that you
want like in this case build essential
for compilers on stuff but you can
install
mongodb uh whatever you want and we have
a d flag at the end in case you need to
execute that command a sudo of course if
the S user don't have pseudo well it's
not going to work but in most cases you
you require pseudo to S and install the
plugins that we
install uh you can manage cond packages
so you can cond install NPI and it's
going to install NPI in all your notes
um you can install from Custom uh
channels if you have packages in your
anaconda server installation or your
ana.org you can install it you can
submit scripts it's just a handy
function uh we didn't really recommend
people to submit jobs that way uh
because an cluster is not a job
management tool you should uh do it
using something else uh you can upload
and and get files uh from the cluster
just a closer put and a closer gate to
download to to your local
machine and then you can
install plugin so a closer install DFS
it's going to inst hdfs it's going to St
High Impala elastic search Keana Lo
stash P notebook a sparking stand mode
sparking jar mode storm ganga uh I
python parallel I missed we have a new
distributed for dusk that is a new tool
that we're building uh and we have a lot
you can have custom Uh custom plugins if
you
want uh for example when you install the
r Essentials in in your cluster you do a
cluster install DC that's the channel
name r Essentials and it's going to
install it in all the notes uh and that
took about like 30 seconds
probably
uh so that's not the cler is not free
but there is a free tool that I built
before I joined continum it still exist
uh it's free an AA cluster uh it doesn't
have documentation it doesn't have a lot
of stuff it's very buggy but if you want
something that's completely free you can
still go and get it you can just P
install Thea science box and you can see
that the commands are really similar
it's like a the predecessor of anonda
cluster um but you should use an aond
cluster it's like the documentation is
better everything works better
there um how does that work uh and both
projects use the very similar approach
that is it's a s for very basic stuff uh
especially for security because a lot of
people like oh yeah I want to manage
user like and we are like okay just give
that user a different say user and
permissions and that way you can manage
your users and the cluster but then we
use uh salt and salt is a configuration
management Tool uh from saltstack that
is completely free and open source is
really fast because it uses uh Ser mq
instead of SSH it's secure uh scales to
thousand of notes uh LinkedIn has a
really big cluster I think that's the
biggest example they have LinkedIn uses
a lot of salt to manage all the all
their
notes um and some nice features is that
you can have declarative language Jam
language instead of B script so you can
for example do Conta that installed and
the name of the package and it's going
to install it in all your notes and you
don't have to write the B script um you
can have like dependencies in this case
I have uh in order to execute this Con
that. install I need the previous state
to file config Das file to be run
successfully if it doesn't run
successfully everything will stop at
that point uh so it's really easy to
create very big formulas um and there's
a lot of formulas online like for
everything that you want mongodb for
example whatever
pogress uh so that's how basically how
Ana cluster and data science uh data
science box works uh that's why it's
really
fast okay the data
um like I said like like or not you have
to move data if you are there scientist
um nobody likes it but you have to do it
uh so the DAT is on a stre
and um to in order to actually use uh
the data you usually want to move it to
your cluster because you want to move
the computation to your data and not the
want yeah not the data to the
computation because the data is big uh
so you move it from a street to htfs and
that's really simple to do using how do
DCP it's a m reduce job it's going to
move all the data in parallel to your
notes if you have a big cluster it's
going to be faster if you have small
closer it's going to take a
well um like I mentioned the data is in
Json and um for this type of analytics
you usually don't want uh the data to be
inj so you want uh some a different
format so in this case I chose
paret par is a columnar storage format
available to any project need had system
regardless of the choice of data
processing framework data model or
programming language and I wish the
programming language part were more true
because it's like actually not that true
uh there is only like uh Java and C
implementations or good implementations
um hopefully a python implementation
will be will becoming
soon and the difference between um a
colum Nary store and a regular store uh
format is that um in the top I have
um what like we have the same table uh
in in in examples but in the in the top
one uh is how the a row or record
oriented uh form is going to store it so
you can see that uh in the small yeah
you can see it in the small
um Brown rectangles you see the row is
is stored in order but in the bottom one
the column is stored in that order uh
and that's usually very that's very
useful when you try to do analytics so
for example Su you only have to read the
column that you want to do like uh give
me the average of SSN I don't know if
you want to do the average of the social
security number but if you want to do it
you can do it uh in that case you only
want to read the social security number
and you don't want to read the name you
don't want to read the age in a record
oriented you have to read the whole file
basically every time you want to do it
but in a column oriented format you
don't uh AER is a really nice format for
that it supports nested data is built
spefic specifically for hdfs but you
don't need to use it in
hdfs um yeah okay uh par is really good
that's what I was trying to say and
we're going to see the the numbers after
this uh once you have your data on xfs
you have to load it into tables because
um uh we're going to be using those
tables to uh do the queries so first I
open the hive um The Hive uh terminal or
the hive CLI and I create a table uh and
these fields I know this fields from the
Json file I had to just go manually and
read them and assign uh the type that I
want so I have the author I have uh if
the post is archived I have uh the
created time in UTC the number of out
vots the number of down votes everything
and I'm using a custom utilizer this
utilizer from Amazon to read the to read
the Json uh values I execute a command I
create a table and then I'm saying to hi
okay move the data from the directory
that I put it from a three and put it
into the uh into the hi table and that
takes maybe 5 seconds because it's just
changing the directory name directory
files and moving to another directory in
htfs and then I'm transforming the data
uh and I'm transforming the data from
the Json file to a park file uh so I
create a different a different type this
in this case rore
Park uh and I just use Hive is a really
simple command to move from one table to
our table insert overwrite table ready
parquet select uh asterisk and then I'm
casting uh the creat a UTC that it was a
string I'm casting it to a time stamp so
parket can actually uh do time
operations on that field and I'm going
to show that after in the
examples when the DAT is in parquet uh I
can uh I can stop using Hive so I'm
going to start talk about impal and hi
hi is a SQL engine uh in top of Hadoop
um it was built by Facebook a long time
ago it based on Google papers uh and it
was um really nice for a while because
it translate your SQL that you write
select aies from blah blah blah to a map
redu job and you can execute the map
redu job in your cluster and in theory
is really fast in practice uh it is fast
for a lot of data but it got like um it
got updated uh let's put it that way it
was a nice iteration and then Cloud
starting uh to work on this new SQL
engine Hado that is Impala uh so it's
not based on map reduce so that makes
stuff a lot faster um it's also build on
C instead of java a lot of a lot of
things the things that uh impal is
really fast and you if you're using H
you should really consider switching to
Impala if you're using the cloud
distribution you already have it uh um
what going to sh numbers after
this how you can quy uh the data you can
just like I say it's a a SQL engine in
top of uh hdfs data so you can do select
count from ready parquet and it's going
to count the number uh you can see this
1.8 billion comments and it took like uh
less than 5 Seconds to read the whole
the whole uh the whole data
set uh but you I mean if you if you like
SQL SQL is really nice SQL is good uh
there is obbc connection JBC connection
for uh Impala you can connect it to
excel like people get really excited
when I say that I don't know why but
apparently people like to connect conect
stuff to excel but you can do it and you
have an DBC connection uh you can
connect it to Tableau for example too uh
but there a scientists usually want to
uh you know write the code uh for to do
their anal analytics so uh what you want
to do is query with python and you want
to do query with a syntax similar to
pandas or
npy uh but in this case you don't Target
local files but you target multiple
distributed engines um so you can Target
SQL uh so Post in palive or spark SQL uh
you can Target no SQL databases like
mongodb or you can still Target your
local files using a similar API to
pandas
andai and there's two projects that try
to do something like this one is called
Blaze from Contin analytics it's an open
source project and one is I that one is
coming from clera and it's written by
Wes mackini the author of pandas I'm
going to talk about both of
them so first Blaze uh so Blaze is an
interface to query data on aor systems
and there was a talk before by Philip
Cloud he's one of the the core
maintainer of Blaze
um the code is on GitHub uh there is a
blaz ecosystem page uh so Blaze used to
be a really big project uh that then had
a lot of spin-offs uh so we have Auto
for moving data uh blaz is still like
the uh right ones Target multiple buend
so there's a lot of projects that is
beenin off of Blaze uh you can check
that page out and um and the code um I'm
going to show the code now so uh it's a
python Library you can go install it P
install it whatever you
want uh and similar to pandas instead of
doing uh for example uh pd. read csb you
create a a data pointer so in this case
I'm using the Impala protocol and I'm
giving a an IP to the Impala one of the
Impala engines that that I have run on
my cluster and then I say uh read the
Reddit parket table that I created
before I see the schema of the data so
that's really nice uh and you can verify
that this schema actually matches the
the one I defined when I created the
table uh once I have the data uh I can
start quering so for example I can do
data. ID this is a column. count and and
this what this is going to do is going
to create an expression this BL
expression this is going to translate it
to SQL and it's going to ship it to
Impala or whatever engine um I'm
targeting um I can see what blaz is
doing here so uh I'm printing a
the translation from the BL expression
to SQL and you can see in this case it's
like SQL count Reddit park. ID because I
said the ID column uh from the
table okay I can do more stuff like
count the number of outputs uh so I
create an expression data. apps that's
the column. sum similar to
pandas uh I can see the SQL equivalent
to that uh really simple SQL at the
moment and I can compute it so and I
think about this like these expressions
like cell number six is not going to
execute anything uh you can create uh
chaining those expressions and what
actually triggers the computation is
when you do uh int or or or evaluation
on on the expression uh on this case it
took like 4 seconds to count the number
of outputs so you can see that it's
really really
fast you can keep uh expanding the
Expressions uh for example in this case
I'm uh counting the number of uh
comments on the soccer subreddit uh and
I can do filtering like in pandas like
in traditional pandas the syntax is
really similar on this
case uh you can see again the SQL uh so
you can see this part right here is the
ID so this part is this uh and the count
is uh so the count is here and but this
one is the wait for it oh yeah this one
is the the filter on the subreddit uh so
this part you can see how the the
expressions are are getting shamed uh
and I'm going to show more examples
after that uh the timing again uh 5
seconds so it's very uh it's very very
fast uh that was 10 notes uh one head
note and nine compute notes how much
does it cost hour uh a little bit uh it
depends it it depends on the on the
machine that you want uh on this case
I'm using Amazon m3.2 x large uh I don't
know if the exact numbers but uh there
is Amazon E2 instance info and you can
see how how much it costs uh I'm asking
if I want to do the Dem no oh you do the
demo uh you can run the demo in maybe
two hours and it's going to maybe less
than 10 bucks yeah I'm pretty sure
yeah
um okay I can do um more expression like
I I if you remember I converted the
created UTC uh string to a created UTC
unor t timestamp uh so for example I can
take a look at the number of comments
before 1 p.m. uh so I do the I I use the
exploration bc. hour uh and I do less
than 13 um that's 1 p.m uh and I count
again uh you can see that this bc. hour
translates to this extract hour from
ready Park UTC that's specific to Impala
uh another SQL and J have a different
SQL Syntax for
this uh I do the i i i trigger the
computation and it it Returns the
result and this is the the the last BL
example it's a more interesting
one and I'm trying to plot the daily
frequency of comments in the ask me
anything
subreddit uh first I start by uh
filtering and then I do this amazing
equation please don't this equation I'm
a verse but okay uh if you don't if you
don't know what is wrong like uh all the
months don't have the same number of
days uh apparently but in my in my world
they do uh it just to show an example
this equation needs to work
um uh and then what I'm doing is doing
bl. transform and I'm what basically is
doing is attaching a new column to the
table that I already have in the
expression um and then I'm going to
group by I can do bc. bu uh you cannot
really there's something oh there's some
underscore that are missing here that
you cannot see the B There is some
underscores here here uh anyways I'm
grouping by day uh and I'm counting
the uh I'm counting the the number of BS
the of of comments on that on that
particular
day uh so again like this uh these cells
like 15 to 18 they don't take anything
to execute like they don't executing
anything they're just creating a graph
uh that is uh chaining the like is
creating a graph that there is going to
be translated to SQL so this this these
commands they don't take anything to run
uh I keep like using the previous
expression to create a more complex
expression uh and then what I can do is
I just put into pandas right uh I just
uh take the result uh and I move it to a
pandas data frame so I can plot it
locally uh and to do that I use Blaze do
auto auto is a project that is a spinoff
it's part of the blaze ecosystem it used
to be on on the blaze core base but we
remov it uh and basically let you move
data between um between different places
so I'm moving data from from a BL
expression to a pandas data frame so
this by day it was my previous
expression and um I'm saying uh put that
into a pandas that data
frame uh and this this is actually going
to trigger the computation uh on the on
Impala uh and then I this by the result
is just a panda data frame uh you can
see the number of uh of post on this day
uh uh because of the formula that I use
this is this do this day uh means
something so I have to do some pandas
stuff here to actually convert that to a
a real date and then I can use bucket to
plot
uh the the number of boats uh and you
can like see that I don't know at the
beginning not a lot of people use it
then it started to get famous uh and
with with with BL with bck you can do
start zooming in uh so that's really
nice and you can start
whoa you can start taking a look at what
days are most famous like in 2013 okay
this not working what's
happening uh you can start to zoom in
uh and for example see that probably May
23 or 20 something was the day that it
was most common so probably someone
famous was on that subreddit uh it just
uh someone famous was doing an an AMA on
that subreddit uh you can see the spikes
they always get a lot of views on those
days uh but I was trying to explain here
is like uh you don't want to move a lot
of data from uh Impala to pandas uh
because that's going to take a while uh
on this case I uh the number of uh the
length of the data frame was like 3,000
so that's that's okay you can just move
that from Impala to to your local
machine and you then you can do Spas uh
you don't want to you want to think
about it when you're using this type of
tools that are going to trigger
computation on remote nodes how much is
how long is going to be the result and
should I actually move that to my local
machine uh especially if you're in a a
coffee shop or something like that it
can take a while if you're running
directly on the cluster uh is going to
be faster because the network is going
to be faster between the notes
especially on
C2 uh okay you can plot it and then you
have five b uh so IB is a similar
project like Blaze but is uh like I said
it's created by Wes mackini he works a
claer now um so you can read the
description here you can look at uh Ibis
project.org he has a really nice blog
there's a lot of documentation too for
Blaze to of course you have a lot of
documentation for everything examples
for everything uh IBC is trying
to uh have a Impalas a first class
citizen uh or Target for their for their
like for the project uh and it's
basically only targeting SQL stuff uh
SQL engines uh with blaze you can Target
not SQL engines if you write the buend
for example it's a pandas engine uh and
you can uh have like a sample of your
data in pandas uh use a BL expression
and then move it to Impala and you don't
have to change anything you have to
change the Target that you're using uh
to create the first uh the First Data
variable but the expressions are exactly
the same between pandas and Impala or
between Hive and Impala so if your it
people finally updated from hive to
Impala you don't have to change your
expression you have to change uh the
target
yes were you saying I direct
connection no Ibis is Impala yeah Ibis
is directly connected to Impala yeah
like uh Impala is the first Target that
IB uh is trying to support yeah they
have a SQL light now and they're working
in uh post and more more SQL engines but
impal is the first class Target for IB
yeah uh Impala is build back loera and
IB also build back loera so it makes
sense that they're targeting Impala as a
first class
citizen uh and you're going to see that
the expressions are really similar so
you import IBS you can import the the
helper function to SQL to actually see
how uh the SQL is
generated uh and then you connect to
Impala so in IB you have to connect an
HD create an hdfs connection and then an
Impala connection and this is just the
hdfs name note and this is the Impala
engine that is running on the
cluster and you can like uh create a
variable from the table and again this
is the rore parket table that I created
at the
beginning uh and this is not doing
anything is not triggering anything it's
just creating a reference to the table I
can uh get the schema uh from the
table archive created dcore T this my
Tim stamp uh and all the stuff uh over
there uh and I'm going to show one
example using IIs uh you can see the
syntax is similar uh I'm trying
to uh get the number of boat of posts
with more than 1K up votes on subreddit
on on
Reddit so I create this expression data
and I filter by the things that are only
more than
1K and then I use my super amazing time
conversion equation please don't use it
um
and then I can uh I have I have to name
this expression so this is how I this
works you have to like create expression
and name it uh and once you name it you
can actually append it append that
column to the to the original table so
this with month is going to be the same
uh columns as before with this new month
uh uh
column and then I can Group by and group
by in I is a little bit different uh
they have this Con of aggregate uh and
you so you create an ex that is going to
be executed when you Group by so the
expression is Count
only uh and you can aggregate the post
by month this is the column that you
want to aggregate
with uh and then you can just do like
execute like this is this works really
similar to to blaze uh everything is
lazy so only when you do execute it's
going to be trigger something on
Impala uh and I think about IBC is it
returns a data frame by default so this
month _ DF is a data frame and again you
can use pandas you can use something
similar and you can PL it with Boke and
you can see the number of out boats um
number of posts with more more than 1K
out vot on on Reddit you can see that of
course is is increasing right this there
was some dips uh during the during some
time like what time is
this okay B is not working
today um like is is the the the screen
resolution doesn't doesn't help me okay
uh whatever doesn't matter
the the conclusion is like there is blaz
there is sideb you can Target uh remote
distributed engines or you can Target uh
your company's database or you can
Target local files uh you don't have to
write the Expressions uh two times you
have you can only write it once and
Target multiple
engines um they're really good you
should use them uh which one to use it's
up to you the expressions are very
similar in some cases and very different
in other cases uh IBC is trying to be
more um that's my that's don't quote me
on this but uh that's my feeling is that
it's trying to be more like uh deep ler
from R uh and blaz is trying to be
something different especially when you
try to Target only SQL you can do some
uh apis that are simpler uh Blaze has uh
more targets are only sequal so the
expressions are tend to be a little bit
different in some cases you should try
them both uh and uh use the one you
like okay so what about a spark because
everybody's happy about a spark uh so
the data is on hdfs is in park and is
happy with and Spark is happy with that
you can create a spark context uh create
a spark SQL context based on your spark
context uh and you can execute SQL using
spark SQL on that parquet uh and then
you can uh uh this teenagers is an
rdd uh and you can do all the stuff that
you can do with regular rdds uh using
this is not of course this is not using
the the data that I I was explaining
before this is an example that I just
copy pasted from uh the spark um
website uh and the nice thing about
spark is that you have like basically
user defined functions or you can apply
you can map reduce whatever function you
want and stuff like that and in Impala
it's a little bit harder because it's a
SQL engine uh there is support for udfs
uh but because uh impal WR Inc it's a
little bit hard to write those uh uh
those um udfs uh especially to actually
develop it really hard you usually have
to download a VM with P installed uh and
actually go write the C compile test and
fail it's really hard to do it um
something nice that happened recently is
using number you can Define your
functions on python uh use number to
create uh an compilate using lvm and
actually you can ship that to Impala so
that's something uh uh some people are
working on I'll be really excited to uh
to see
it okay and the wrap up is like uh we
can make the sci uh access to Big Data
tools easier uh so both uh creating
clusters and managing clusters and
making queries and making uh queries to
run uh faster and you don't have to
actually write big SQL I I actually like
I didn't show like the big sequels that
this produce uh but they get ridiculous
like if people have written SQL like the
example that I showed like oh yeah I can
write that SQL right like it's not that
hard it's select an account uh but
people know that uh people who work with
SQL know that um like 10 lines of SQL
like no one can after understand that
and maintaining that is really hard uh
while maintaining this uh you can
actually see this what is this is doing
and you can read it and anybody can read
this and understand it anyone who can
who has used pandas you can like oh yeah
this is filtering getting the hour L
than and count while this uh you see it
and you're like okay I get it but if you
add one more line I'm not going to get
that uh and this final expression it was
like 20 15 to 20 lines so uh it gets
harder to
maintain
um but data scientists need to
understand underly Big Data Technologies
and devops tools to some degree uh and
that's something that happens a lot of
my work like people want a magic
solution and there is no magic solution
for everything for anything um people
need to understand the things that
they're doing people have to understand
in P some degree people need to
understand part to some degree like uh
if you were at the machine learning
panel yesterday people were given a lot
of
uh not good things about a spark that
are deserve because spark is like it's
not the best tool ever uh you get all
this Java mem memory hper erors you have
to understand jarn you have to
understand all the stuff and if you just
don't do it and the and the and your man
like yeah you need to use a spark and
you're like yeah but I don't know Java
and you get this Java error well you're
going to be like stuck there for for
days and weeks and that happens a lot so
if you don't understand the tools uh
there is nothing that uh no one can do
for you if you don't understand how to
safe or how uh a security group works
like there is no one can help you no one
can help you with that uh yeah like you
have to go there and learn that
um or pay me money and I'll I I'll te
you
uh uh some of these tools are like
uh all these SQL type queries are like
are really useful for for bi uh like I
was saying like people are really
excited when I tell them like oh yeah
you can connect it to Excel and do a sh
in Excel uh and I'm like for
real that happens um but for more
advanced analytics other tools are
needed so for example the spk so machine
learning right machine learning is like
oh yeah you can do machine learning
spark uh so Impala and SQL engines in
top of had doop are not going to help
you to do machine learning um but most
of the cases 99% of the case no not 99
don't quote me on this but a lot of
cases you just need SQL and you're fine
uh and if you need to do much learning
well you can use second learn just
reduce your data and do in a big note
uh okay and finally just download anonda
cluster or data science box try it for
yourself uh I have a lot of uh since the
since they Reddit uh since that user
published the code on Reddit the data on
Reddit a lot of people have been
creating posts about what they found out
with the data uh so you can like the
most popular domain share on Reddit from
2007 to 2015 so that's a really nice I
think that's kind of useful you know
like uh I bet that is uh an image look
inside because people that's what people
on red images uh but you can see a lot
of stuff uh the average number of outs R
submission containing a given keyword
for each of the top uh 50s this is a
really nice one I don't think I have
internet to show it um but yeah uh
tested uh the data is there is free yeah
you can get it you need an Amazon
account uh download an AA cluster uh
tweet me yeah I'll help you with your
spark eror uh uh yeah that's it thank
you
yep used to be that to
dat
so
what what are meaning
differences
um that's a nice
question um I think it's I think it
just is a it's a natural evolution of
the of the of the Big Data stock
um like you were saying like you have we
we already saw like like this Evolution
uh in the small data or the local data
uh like pandas came or and or our data
frames came after a while and people
start to using them uh and now you're
seeing the same thing happening in the
Big Data ecosystem uh like you were
saying spark has data frames
now uh I think it I don't really know
what to say in that case I think it
really depends on the on what you're
trying to do uh and the tools that you
know already and the tools that you want
to learn like these type of tools are
like if you already know pandas people
most people already know pandas well of
course here right uh they know pandas
this is just going to be Supernatural
for them uh uh you don't have to you
don't have to train a lot to to use
these tools that that's what I can say I
don't know
yeah yeah like
definitely
yeah so like spark is written in a Scala
that is based on that is a j a jvm
language so it runs on top of the jvm uh
so if you are using uh spark and you're
using Scala you're going to be fine
probably because you know Scala and
you're used to like the type of uh stuff
you see in Scala but if you're using
python you have to use py spark and P
spark is based on pi4j so basically it's
trying to serialize stuff and sending
from python to the J to to to a Java
process uh and what you what you see a
lot is like uh I have my rdd uh I I did
my map and reduced my filter and then I
do collect and everything goes to hell
um you and what happens is like okay if
it's an error in my code I can fix it
you know if I if I get a like a value
error uh in Python I see that I'm
indexing wrong probably right but what
you see in in in spark is like uh oh
yeah this you have a class that I didn't
write that the spark people wrote uh
there was an error an error on this line
and you're like okay but I didn't write
that what is error on my code uh so
that's why you have to start uh that's
what you see a lot with uh with a spark
um yeah you get a lot of Java memory you
have to like to run it on on top of
Jan uh Jan is a resource scheduler for
for the Hadoop uh ecosystem and and you
have like a million settings on uh
containers uh CPU per container memory
per container maximum minimum whatever
uh so if you have a big data set uh on
hdfs and you try to load it into uh an
rdd and then you try to collect what
happens usually is that the master
process of spark doesn't have enough
memory to collect all the data and
that's when you get like memory errors
and you're like okay but I'm just trying
to do collect what's happening right now
see like and it's usually because the
master process doesn't have enough
memory to do it so the computation runs
fine and then you're trying to move it
to to see the result and you never see
the result uh so that that happens a lot
with the spark um
uh my experience with impal is that uh
it runs much better uh it doesn't Crush
that often uh it's not like the crashes
it's like uh you you you type your SQL
and it runs and you get the result like
in a spark you have to work a lot to get
the result sometimes uh depending on the
data
[Music]
yeah okay thank
[Applause]
you